Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive into
the third season of Stranger Things, the easter
eggs you might have missed and the crucial
details from the ending and the post-credits
scene that set things up for season 4.
Plus I'll explain exactly how the show tricked
you about Hopper in the finale.
I've got a Stranger Things giveaway on this
video, so subscribe, hit the bell and let
me know what you thought of the new season
for a chance to win!
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care if
you're not all caught up.
Unlike Season 2 where Eleven closed the gate
and cut the Mind Flayer off from the Demodogs,
this time El has lost her powers for the moment,
so it's up to Joyce and Hopper to get to the
gate and destroy the machine that's keeping
it open.
As they try to turn the machine off, Hopper
is attacked by the Terminator-like Russian.
Although Hop manages to push the goon into
the spinning machine, time is running out
to save the day, so he nods to Joyce signalling
that she has to shut the machine down herself
even though he's standing right next to it
which puts him in great danger.
As the machine explodes, some nearby Russian
scientists disintegrate, the gate closes and
the connection between the Mind Flayer behind
the gate and its monster inside the mall is
broken, killing the beast.
Now, if you're upset that Hopper was killed
in the explosion, there are plenty of clues
to suggest that's not the case.
First of all, after Joyce turned the keys
to shut down the machine, the screen conveniently
cut to black suggesting at least a few seconds
of time passed and that something happened
off screen.
And as Joyce turns those keys, she looks down
and away from the platform presumably because
she can't bear to see what she thinks will
happen to Hopper.
In reality though, it means that she wouldn't
have seen Hopper leave the platform.
Because in the next shot, as we watch the
spinning machine go out of control and explode,
if you look really closely at the platform
where Hopper was standing, you'll see there's
nobody there anymore.
So, where did he go and why hasn't anyone
heard from him?
Well, there are a few possibilities including
one that the show hints at in the mid-credits
scene at the end of the season.
In this bonus scene, we discover that the
Russians are feeding human prisoners to a
Demogorgon.
But more crucially we find out that they've
got an American prisoner in one of their cells.
If Hopper got off the platform before the
explosion and escaped into the nearby room
that Joyce and Murray run into later, it's
quite possible that he bumped into a group
of Russians who apprehended him and hauled
him off to Russia.
Another theory is that Hopper didn't have
time to find a safe exit before the machine
exploded and the gate closed, so rather than
stick around and risk being fried, he jumped
through the gate and is now stuck in the Upside
Down.
"Three-inch minimum!
Leave the door open three inches!"
Perhaps that what the show is hinting at when
it shows Hop turn and look at the gate before
it closes.
And don't forget that Hopper has been in the
Upside-Down before when he went looking for
Will with Joyce.
If he is now on the other side, there's no
immediate way out for him unless he can find
a breach back to our world, like El did at
the start of Season 2.
A twist on this idea is that sometime after
Hopper jumped over to the other dimension,
the Russians figured out how to open up their
own connection to the Upside Down at their
base in Russia, and he emerges through there
which is how he's ended up in their cell.
An alternative theory is that the machine
the Russians developed has some similarities
to a particle accelerator, and that when it
blew up in Hawkins, it caused a rift in time
and space sending Hopper backwards in time
to the same location, for example, a year
ago, at which point he was captured by the
Russians.
The final episode did have some heavy Back
To The Future references, so perhaps that's
what they were hinting at?
The other big clue that Hopper survived is
that the song "Heroes" plays while El is reading
Hop's "Heart to Heart" letter.
That same song played in the first season
when Will Byers' dead body was discovered,
and, as we all know, Will's death proved to
have been a fake and he's still clearly alive.
And remember that, Hopper's adopted daughter,
El, also seemed to die at the end of season
1, disintegrating as she took out the Demogorgon.
So, there's definitely hope for Hop!
Now, although I'm convinced Hopper is still
alive somewhere, there are some alternative
possibilities for who the mysterious American
is inside the Russian cell.
Another character who's been heavily suggested
to still be alive is Dr Brenner, aka Eleven's
"Papa".
Although Brenner was mauled by the Demogorgon
in season 1, when El and her sister Kali visited
one of his ex-colleagues in the second season,
he claimed that Brenner was still alive:
"Brenner!
I can take you to him."
"Papa is gone."
"No, he is alive."
If Ray knew where Brenner was, it's quite
possible that the Russians tracked down the
former director of the Hawkins lab, to take
him captive and help them open a gate to the
Upside Down.
Another possibility is that one of Eleven's
siblings from the Rainbow Room is locked in
the cell.
But it's also possible that the unnamed American
in the cell is an entirely new character being
introduced for Season 4.
The other big revelation from the post-credits
scene is that the Russians are in control
of a Demogorgon.
Which could mean a couple of things.
They may have discovered the Demogorgon during
their time in Hawkins, as we saw they had
extra tall cages and electric cattle prods
which were presumably for containing the monsters.
Or it might be proof that the Russians have
now managed to open their own gate to the
Upside Down in Russia just as we saw them
trying to do in the opening scene of season
3.
We can't discuss the finale of season 3, of
course, without talking about Billy and the
Mind Flayer's new monster.
After the Mind Flayer was driven out of Will's
body in Season 2, the black particles weren't
destroyed entirely and season 3 reveals that
they ended up at the abandoned steel works
building outside Hawkins.
When the Russians open up the gate to the
Upside Down in their base below Starcourt
Mall, those black particles are reactivated.
In fact, Will's Stranger Sense or Will Tingle
is triggered when he feels the monster's presence
again after a swarm of nearby rats run past
him and into the Brimborn Steel Works building.
The Mind Flayer now begins to slowly build
a new body for itself, starting with these
rats which burst open and combine to form
a new monster.
The Mind Flayer then causes Billy to crash
his car, using the opportunity to possess
him and use him not only as a human spy in
Hawkins, like the big bad did with Will in
Season 2, but also to gather human victims.
"I want you to build."
"To build what?"
"What you see."
The possessed Billy starts with his Lifeguard
colleague Heather and the pair then move on
to her parents.
By the sixth episode, Billy has amassed around
30 people, who are now called "the Flayed"
as they act like normal people until the Mind
Flayer activates them.
At this point they all converge to the steel
works building where they melt down into a
mess of bones and flesh and join the body
of the monster which grows bigger with each
new body it absorbs.
And this is the meaning of the Latin title
of the episode "E Pluribus Unum" which translates
as "Out of many, one", and fits with this
season's 4th of July Independence Day-setting
as that phrase is also the original motto
of the United States.
Before they join with the monster though,
the Flayed humans and rats will often consume
toxic amounts of fertilizer and chemicals.
It may be that the monster feeds off and grows
bigger from these chemicals, but the consumption
of these is also so that the human or animal
body is physically weakened and will easily
melt and break down.
Making this probably the grossest monster
on the show so far!
As the Mind Flayer's human spy for locating
Eleven, Billy is kept alive until the finale
where he's able to pin down El in the mall
after she loses her powers.
Billy is about to offer Eleven to the monster,
but she helps him regain control of his mind
when she connects with him and reminds him
of his childhood with his mother.
Billy's self-sacrifice as he stands up to
the monster to stop it from getting to Eleven
gives him a nice redemption arc and in this
case, unlike with Hopper, we did see his dead
body, so I don't think he'll be coming back
to Hawkins, unless it's in flashbacks via
Eleven or his stepsister Max.
Cover-ups of what's really been going on in
Hawkins continue with the general population
still seemingly unaware of the secret Russian
installation in the town or the fact that
it was the Mind Flayer's monster which was
responsible for destroying the Starcourt Mall
on the Fourth of July.
The Cutting Edge exposé that runs on TV three
months later focuses blame for the mysterious
goings-on and missing people on a corrupt
mayor and local government, chemical leaks,
and the programme even suggests that Satanism
may be at fault and links that to playing
Dungeons and Dragons
"Some believe a rise in Satanism is to blame.
To find out, tune in tonight at 8:00 p.m.
for 'Horror in the Heartland'"
Which is incredibly something some groups
have complained about in reality!
The TV documentary reminds me of how back
in Season 2, Murray told Nancy and Jonathan
that to reveal what had happened to Barb,
they needed to "water down" their story to
make it more palatable to the general public.
"Perhaps Barbara was exposed to some dangerous
toxins."
"A leak from the lab.
Like Three Mile Island or something."
"Something scary but familiar."
Interestingly enough, Season 3's secret Russian
invasion was partially predicted by Murray
himself right at the beginning of Season 2.
"I believe there was, and may still be, a
Russian spy presence in Hawkins."
"Russian spy?!"
"I'm talking a full-on Russian invasion right
here in Hawkins."
Murray might have been wrong about Eleven
being one of those Russians, but when Dr Owens
arrives at the end of season 3 and discovers
what's happened, he might be thinking back
to this conversation he had with Nancy and
Jonathan in season 2:
"Let's say, the Soviets...
If they heard about our mistake...
do you think they would even consider that
a mistake?
What if they tried to replicate that?"
After all that happened in season 3, I wonder
if Season 4 will find Murray relocating as
he did say that Hopper and Joyce had compromised
his secure hideaway.
Since the end of Season 2 when the Mind Flayer
was shown watching over Hawkins School as
the ultra creepy song 'Every Breath You Take'
played, it's been hinted that the shadowy
monster has had his eye on Eleven.
And indeed she did turn out to be his ultimate
target this season, presumably in revenge
for her closing the gate in Season 2 and foiling
the Demogorgon in Season 1, and also because
it sees her as the main threat to its larger
plan for domination of our world.
After the monster bit Eleven and infected
her leg, it seems the Mind Flayer may have
at least temporarily weakened El, depowering
her for the final episode.
This worked as a convenient plot device to
avoid a repeat of the season 2 finale where
Eleven did all the work of closing the gate,
but it also means that El can't search for
Hopper to confirm if he's really gone or not.
Mike is confident that Eleven's powers will
return and I expect this will be an important
part of her arc in Season 4.
The season ends with Joyce, Will and Jonathan
moving away from Hawkins taking Eleven with
them.
This splits up the gang, however, Mike mentions
meeting up around Thanksgiving and Christmas.
I suspect that rather than Season 4 taking
place during the 1985 winter holidays, it'll
be set around a year and a half after the
events of Season 3, putting it towards the
end of 1986, which will roughly keep it in
line with how the young actors are growing
up off screen.
And I wonder if Dustin will try and invite
his girlfriend Suzie for another rendition
of "The Neverending Story" or if she could
even travel from Utah to join them on their
next adventure?
Oh, and assuming Hopper does return next season,
I wonder if he'll be rocking his full-on Tom
Selleck as Magnum PI look again?
"That's a lot of color for you, Chief."
It's cutting-edge!"
After all, I think Hop's love of Magnum isn't
just about what he calls the character's "cutting-edge"
look, but also about the fact that they're
both veterans of Vietnam.
One thing missing from Season 3 was any continuing
story about Kali who El met last season, but
if Dr Brenner does come back into play next
season we could see Kali or the other gifted
children from the Hawkins Lab appear.
You can learn more about them and the dark
history of Brenner's MK Ultra experiments
in my Stranger Things Gifted Children video.
Tap the screen here or check the link in the
video description.
Now, what are your opinions and theories about
season 3?
And how do you think Hopper survived the explosion?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe to enter my
Stranger Things giveaway.
Next tap left for that Stranger Things theory
video or tap right for another video you're
sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a like, share and
subscribe are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!